he's the head coach of the New York
Knicks made the trip up here to the man
cave got chance to see the basketball
court and a little bit of the dinettes
warming up coach thank you for staying
because I thought that maybe you would
want to get out of the building no that
was great
I've never seen an archery guy yeah Paul
he's an archery guy yeah and Paulie
Paulie who has one good eye and he's an
archer so he sees coach and he goes hey
I'm not a basketball player I'm an
archer have you ever met a basket met a
player who said I'm an archer no never
never in my life and especially one with
a bad eyes yeah other than that but
during the next live look in if you
could assess their game and maybe help
them out a little bit that would be nice
I may be able to assess but I don't know
how much help I can give them what do
you think of the man cave here this is
fantastic
yeah I mean you built it out perfect oh
man you got the matchups on the wall
that we all would have loved to see you
got a setup that's how we would like it
if we were sitting around watching games
this is the Anacin square garden is what
this may be if you want to bring your
team up and they want to play a little
practice right here yeah you got a nice
setup how are you is your game how was
your game now do you play at all it's
better it's better in my mind that it is
we of course the older I get the better
I was yeah but you were like a
eight-point per game guy yeah I was I
was close to double figures but I could
pass that was always my Amaka move the
ball who plays in the NBA now the way
you played in college I think they
starting to get rid of guys like the
closest thing I think that you--that
you've seen to a NBA guy as me as Andre
Miller oh yeah he played like 15 years
and we grew up in the same kind of
neighborhood so I think we end up
getting the same influences somehow and
when you when you don't have a deep
threat three and you're a bigger guard
maybe not as quick as two other guys you
learn how to do other things and you
were in South Central growing up born
right yeah best player in the
neighborhood was who at that time but
that's how I was saying our neighborhood
was Kevin ollie
okay went to UConn yeah Crenshaw High
School
kevin and i played on the same junior
high team he was he was in that that
time in the city he was probably the
best player your coaching adventures
here you were with the Miami Heat
and what was the official title that you
had with the Miami Heat were you video
coordinator no no I wasn't that much I
don't even think I had her title really
it was like I was just an intern and
they made me do everything you know I
was a brokedown film deck to deck you
know back in the old days you had to do
a VCR to VCR we didn't have that but you
got LeBron and Wade and Bosh that was
later yeah how was way later yeah yeah
that was way that was that that was my
second run in Miami I was there for a
year with spokes Paul and I were in the
dungeon in the video room for it for one
year and then I left and went in coach
college and then made my rounds back
through the NBA ESPO got the job as head
coach and brought me back 13 years later
what's your favorite LeBron story in
Miami
you got a it's got a good sense of humor
we see a practical joker oh yeah yeah
every day no one was safe that was the
rules in the in the locker room no one
was safe which meant you can't have a
you can't be a guy that's all hung up on
you know when you're getting teased in
things so he's roughing on the D Wade
Bosh and it was going right back at him
did he make fun of Pat Riley behind his
back that would be tough to do it
tomorrow space what's he know he arouses
great with that stuff we were we were
dollars a raw team you know cuz we had
to be raw with each other we were
getting a lot from the outside and we
just felt like inside inside those doors
we had to build real trust and so that
team was really wrong with each other
and we tried to keep it real with each
other every time I see on the court I
always think that I would see you in a
jazz club like you strike me as somebody
who's just chill Oh like you're mean I
wouldn't say mean I just maybe what I'm
feeling on the inside isn't showing on
the outside but I'm definitely got a
and I think my players will tell you you
know what makes you man how do I know
you're mad well you can say when I get
texts I mean I think I was ranked pretty
high and losing money section have you
tried to get a technical I've tried
before yes did you ever try and not get
a technic s that's the screwed-up part
about it I get on what I'm not really
trying to get her but I'm mad but then
when I tried to get him a couple of
times they laughed at me like no we're
not even gonna bail you out right now
you know well what why would the serving
Lisa why were you trying to get bailed
out no you know you're always trying it
maybe you'll find out you're trying to
set a tone for you Tom or send a message
that you're defending a guy on your team
or you know you okay they're smart
they'll catch you and they'll just go no
we're not gonna give you a tech today
have you ever bought a referee a drink
like been in a restaurant or hotel bar
and just no no never picked up the
dinner time for a referee ever gone to
dinner with referees no any interest in
going to dinner with referees I mean I I
like them I they're good guys I just
don't know how that ways in the whole
scheme of like tampering and stuff you
know you don't want to get too
comfortable I don't think it's not
taking you know you're buddy-buddy with
the rest and now all the sudden you get
a good game call for you everybody has
pride in these jobs
and everybody wants to win a
championship and you you're with the
Miami Heat
and you're you're winning championships
you're with the Knicks and you know
people are either laughing at you or
with you you're not quite sure you have
an unbelievable fan base but your pride
itself every night when you go out there
knowing that you're under man but they
play hard like how do you how do you
compartmentalize that we're probably
going to lose but I still have to coach
I have to expect greatness out of these
jets I said you know I said what I tried
to do this year understanding that we
were up against you know up against
difficult conditions was that okay what
are the goals that are realistic for
this team you know what are the things
that I can put in front of them that
they can actually go after individually
and collectively you know even late in
the season you know guys don't really
have a reason to play
but I just looked at the schedule and I
saw seven games there the last seven
games and and it kind of played out like
a playoff schedule like a like a seven
game series and I said okay guys we're
not getting to that next playoff right
now let's play these games like it's the
playoffs and let's see if we can win a
seven-game series we lost in the game
seven but the fact that they were
engaged in that and they list for that
it gave them a goal to pursue so little
things like that throughout the season I
put that in front of him a lot how does
the losing affect you you know it was
moments during the season where it was
heavy but again I had to reel it in and
not just back there yeah it's very
difficult and you you know you the
things that sometimes you have to catch
yourself because you're like questioning
and doubting like man do I really know
what the hell like did he really just do
that is that something I taught over
like do you know in this so you go
through all of that as a coach you know
you take it home with you but at the
same time you know you got to check
yourself and it's a lot of moving parts
to this thing and you know when you're
looking at it was a chunk of a huge
chunk of the season until a couple of
guys had birthdays that we were the
youngest team in the history since more
like an NBA team and so when you hear
that you gotta go wait a minute keep it
in perspective you know let's see if we
can just keep getting these guys better
hunt for wins what we can get him he's
the head coach of the New York Knicks
David phys Dale and the pride of
University of San Diego torero
yeah yeah killing it didn't Tony Gwynn
go to San Diego they owe the rival woo
and Tony Gwynn was a baller Oh big-time
athlete Tony tony was really good sport
or yeah he could hope and what is your
role in the offseason for the Knicks
with the draft do you know I County
agency I think you know my part in free
agency is is to paint the picture from a
coach's standpoint of what the Knicks
are becoming
and you know try to really make players
understand the type of relationship I'm
trying to build it as a coach with them
and the type of team we're trying to
build moving forward ultimately to win a
title and showing that from a coach's
perspective you know with with our guys
I turned back into a player development
coach you know with the guys that we
have on the roster and you know like
last week and I don't know how many kids
are actually in the gym with their
coaches right now but Kevin Knox wanted
to get back in the gym know I like that
and I don't know any kids in April you
know this was in April in this kid is
like coach let's do it and he and I went
into the gym for the whole week and I
just went back into assistant coach mode
and you know got the bags and started
hitting them and and drilling them and
going through the whole deal and you
know for me it rejuvenates me when I do
that here's a hypothetical let's say
there's a seven footer out there and
he's like he lives on the west coast and
and you were great shooter one of the
great shooters maybe man he was looking
for a new team to play for how would you
make that free agent pitch to just an
unnamed 7 footer who was an unbelievable
scorer who lives in the Bay Area no
names
there's no names there but you know Dan
I'm not gonna play my hand right okay no
it's things that won't people were we're
in competition with mmm hand out our
cards if you win the lottery
yes let's say you won the lottery you
know who you're taking if we win the
lottery you know we're taking yeah yes
Paulie bring out Zion Wiggins in here
[Applause]
was that your poker face there they just
sit no no I thought you were trying to
give me a poker face you know I look at
the Phoenix Suns and Jama rant may fit
their team better than Zion wood so I'm
curious about that design fit everybody
you know Cavaliers obviously but if you
look at how he would fit on the Knicks
does he make the most sense for you he's
got the biggest brand but I
thing just for us you know our roster is
so open from that standpoint that we can
have a lot of things fit us right now
obviously you know we always want the
biggest talent you know you wanna do you
want to see electric players and both of
those guys you just named or that
they're electric you know when you watch
them play who does I own remind you know
one that's interesting because we always
look for player comps because John
Marant is like d-wade to me to thin but
he attacks the hoop might be a better
outside shooter than d-wade better
passer than d-wade but yeah you're right
I mean d-wade was built but Zion we keep
saying way he's like Charles Barkley
who's like LeBron easily and I said I I
don't know if he's like those guys his
own guy no unique when do you get a
chance to talk to these guys that
stuff's coming up we got Chicago free
draft camp coming and I want to say we
can have two weeks where we see a lot of
these other guys go through draft
workouts we interview with them we do
that stuff and then right at the end of
the month we'll start bringing guys in
to work out and eventually you know meet
with those top guys I always said that
when we had the NFL Combine I want to
sit down and talk to you because I
already see what you do on tape the
importance of talking to somebody as
opposed to looking at their tape to you
how important is that news you just said
what are you listening for I want to
know the true kid I want to know who
they are I want to hear the truth from
him I want to know honest answers I want
to hear the raw what kind of questions
would you ask where you get that
information no we get you know we do so
much background on these guys and so you
know when we started getting into their
backgrounds you can start asking some
real point of questions that can get
into the character of the kid you know
the type of worker that they are you
know
how hungry they are and all of those
things you can start digging into those
things and you know what kind of leader
are they you can learn a lot from these
guys and I like to hear that face to
face you're the first guest who's
brought in an axe to the man cave if you
would lift it up there and explain what
what is the story behind the axe that
you brought in here so because I knew
our team was gonna have a tough year we
were in Sequoia National Forest trying
to chop down a redwood mmm and we're
starting from the beginning so our deal
was we got to keep chopping that tree
and so we all signed two acts as a team
and made a commitment as a group that no
matter what happens this year we'd all
gonna keep swinging at the tree and you
can't carry that on the plane Kenya why
not I don't know can you the team
charter you can bring an axe on the team
charter what about this subway in New
York have you guys had ax night no we
haven't but why don't you get axe
deodorant to sponsor and you thinking
coach dad I don't think you know I'm
like tunnel vision you know you got to
think outside the box so where you gonna
put this are you gonna put it in the
stream line you want wait is that mine
yeah this is oh you brought an X this is
oh damn I didn't know that Wow oh man
you know I broke it out on my team every
now and then just to remind them what I
could do with it damn look at these
fritzy bring come on over here put your
hand down here let me see if it works
I'm gonna sorry I'm gonna find a good
spot for this and then maybe it lowers
like what was it Anne Boleyn is she the
one who da 0 - chopping limbs off mask
has a beautiful name ask Patrick with
the yai McLovin radiant beauty radiant
beauty right this is this is awesome
Thank You coach I appreciate a green
room you got to tell me about the green
room back there it was it a streamline
the Airstream Airstream yeah I won't
want to go so bad I want to put it in my
backyard and put like where no one can
come in unless I buzz a man yeah it'd be
great for my office tonight film I had
an Airstream I brought bought it for my
wife for our anniversary and then I
needed a place to park it and so I said
well why don't we just make it the green
room right and I I just I brought that
in and I brought out all the Sandler
posters because I hear your big Sandler
fan fan
who's that okay he loves the Knicks and
he loves to play ball loves to shoot
jumper no he can shoot he's always he
always kind of showing it off a little
bit
I noticed that how about a one-day
contract for Adam Sandler a lot of
people behind that or put you put him in
the lamp line that would go big
are you allowed to do that I don't think
putting them in again would be safe for
him well I appreciate it maybe a little
layup line action with Adam Sandler and
Tracy Morgan in the mail oh how great
would that be
Tracy knows his hoops oh listen he's
he's over there barking command he's got
to get a play call in like who do you
talk to of the celebrities that sit
courtside oh I don't know any of these
guys I haven't I haven't gotten to know
any of Howard Sharon goes you know I
just waited from afar and I see him
sitting across from me and I'm like you
you know who Howard Stern is oh yeah
okay yeah Howard goes there he's tall
enough to be a player he's not neat has
no athleticism I'll bow to his Howard
it's gonna be yeah that's gonna hurt
Chris Rock Chris can't play I don't
think so completely you know what if you
get Zion you're gonna have a lot of new
friends courtside about it yeah do you
want to take a look at these guys during
the commercial break do I have to
yeah just for morale purposes okay yeah
I know you had a rough year and I'm
going to extend it a little time I know
I'm saying I like it just whisper right
and also I would like for you are you
capable of telling me how to guard James
Harden nah I can give you what I could
talk about like fearing what everyone
tries to do in theory okay but
ultimately okay who is the one guy that
you just you threw up your hands and you
say I there's nothing
hardened hardened over Durant or the
Greek freak because of the stuff you
know they all do those things but you
know what continuously do I want to I
want you to show me on the court of what
but harden does and how you can possibly
slow them down
coach phys Dale the New York Knicks here
will come back and if you're watching on
BR live.com an audience Channel 239
DirecTV you're able to see coach put the
identity through the paces well we're
coming back here on the Dan Patrick show
up to this this was a grapefruit okay I
want you to assess the damage
by the way McLovin controlling you today
we see there's one thing we know for
sure we know who's gonna run the
[Music]
impression is that all right okay I'm
gonna try though okay what worked on
that's not bad
the orchard the left okay nice all go in
with this side all right now that this
is Francisco to shot you think yeah and
he usually shoot nobody is captured
cream ritzy with the same high school
all right so through the magic of TV and
radio we're on the basketball court here
in the man cave with a coach phys Dale
the Knicks I want you if you can even
through the magic of radio explain what
you do against James Hart now you
already said he's the most frustrating
player in the game now if I'm harden and
you're teaching telling your kids how to
guard harden here's the few ways I've
told him to borrow harden and none of
them have work so first thing we talk
about is maybe picking them up way back
in the backcourt and making them work
harder okay right fresh wrong I mean
midcourt you're picking him up even
further if you can okay alright and
that's you don't want to get overzealous
and open up a lie for him to just blow
by you but you want to make them work
but once he starts to get in the
shooting range which is about half pork
butt okay so we're Pat we're out by the
three-point line yeah further advisory
NBA three putting that Dame Lillard yeah
deep zone there curry okay so what most
teams are trying to do right now is push
him to his right hand yeah well I think
what everybody's starting to see now is
he went into the summer and worked on a
few things going to his right hand now
and that's not helping because what it
pushes him into now is his best shot
which is taking you this way and
clearing space and stepping back away
from you and that's his best way of
shooting step back says with his right
hand here getting that ball to his left
hand there so you got a dilemma do I
force him to his we can and it's the
path the hand that he doesn't pass as
well with but he's better shooter going
right up and back to that to that area
or do I send them to his strong hand
where he turns the corner he's dunking
he's a better passer and he still has a
really good step back going that way as
well but why do they allow him to get
away Tim Hardaway was one of the greats
yeah
creating separation harden will go left
create and then he's here that's now you
ask me why they let him get away what do
[Laughter]
you have more of a problem with the
footwork where he looks like I do or the
way I'm always complaining about down
there that's what I don't need the
footwork if I create separation but you
know what he does a good job of with
that where I couldn't you know it's not
too much where I don't get too involved
with this is because he's he's big guy
yes right and he does a good job of just
getting his shoulder and tell you enough
where he doesn't fully but once he
decides to go backwards I'm coach they
sent a video around to all you guys to
say it's not traveling show me your
rotation okay who's next guy so harden
is unstoppable rule who would be next
that you just say Yanis okay even though
he doesn't have that that branch
Guilford yeah because of just I think
it's not just him alone
it's what bud has done around them and
how they space the floor now around them
if it's just created this one-on-one
situation with a lion but
so it feels like he's gotten longer yeah
it or utilized his length not only
stronger alright yeah he's a beast and
the thing with him is because he's so
big is once he gets you going the
direction and you'll see him do this a
lot you have to fully commit to stopping
him with your whole body and what he
does is he spins off of you all the time
he'll take one step you have to take two
or three and right and he unravels
he's like a ladder okay that's where
he's but Durant has kept the mid-range
jump for a lot stoppable in that area
but when do you know like if where does
he get where you know you can't stop him
I just felt like I've always felt like
playing against him that if he gets the
ball gathered into his hands you just
it's a maker miss thing now it's nothing
that you could be stagnant because I
thought about Dirk Dirk was the same way
no 7-foot shooters those guys that just
they don't see you down here they just
once they get that ball gathered I've
always felt like it's just too difficult
coach we have a request for coach miss
Dale yeah you know how when players
shoot free throws I don't even need the
ball but like okay my here's my
teammates uh-huh let's say I miss the
free throw or making okay can we get rid
of that can you lead the charge you
should've made the free throw to get
down see we didn't really do that but
you could you're the ball on the next
cone we never did that mess with my I'm
locked in here at the line you eliminate
that you know I don't know the Players
Association might have show you how to
do that but you know if you ever heard
Jason Terry talk about how his free
throws got better they found they were
paying attention to his free throws in
Dallas and he was shooting and already
going to and so he had to back it off
and like slow down
okay four more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on VR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app